vamos a hacer la siguiente suma cuánto
será 0.8 22 5.65 como en el ejemplo
anterior lo primero que haremos es
reescribir estos números de tal manera
que los puntos decimales nos queden
perfectamente alineados esto nos hará lo
siguiente a mí me gusta poner primero el
número más grande entonces será 5.65
más
primero pondré el punto que es este y
tengo hacia la izquierda un 0 y a la
derecha 822
así es que haré la suma aquí tengo 12
columnas en el número de arriba y tengo
3 columnas en el número de abajo así es
que rellenar esta columna con un 0
recuerden que el punto hacia la derecha
podemos hacer esto rellenar únicamente
aquellos que nos queden del lado derecho
y sumemos entonces la idea de sumar esto
será a partir del lado derecho hacia la
izquierda tal como lo hemos hecho con
todas las sumas porque porque en caso de
que tengamos un número superior vamos a
arrastrar ese número hacia la izquierda
ok
empezamos 0 + 2 es igual a 2
52 es igual a 7
6 + 8 es igual a 14 lo mismo que
equivale a 4 y llevo una unidad recuerda
que 10 décimos son una unidad y aquí
tendríamos 14 decimos entonces pondremos
el 4 y nos llevaremos el 1 hacia la
izquierda y ahora sumamos 15 es igual a
seguimos en 6 bajaremos el punto no lo
queremos olvidar y tenemos entonces que
5.650 + 0.8 22 es igual a 6.472 o seis
unidades 472 milésimos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo